Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two.
David P..
The San Antonio troll is known for one thing
on this show for nearly a decade.
He calls in and criticizes me for things I
have never said.
A particularly manic troll from San Antonio
called in, unable to control himself, still
criticizing me for things I certainly never
said.
I don't do it.
Oh, sorry.
Let's take it from the top pack rat.
Speaker 6: I'm just wondering, do you ever
do something for humans who don't do any of
the work is just on your mind, if you like?
Speaker 1: I mean, I don't know.
I've never said Trump's on the verge of death.
I don't even know what this is in reference
to coughs or sniffles.
Speaker 6: You know, you've done this about
everywhere.
None of them have died.
I think Carnahan was the only one that died.
We all were on the verge of death or about
to die.
Speaker 1: Well, when it's been reported that
people are actually on the verge of death,
like the many radio hosts who were, you know,
in a in a medically induced coma for weeks
and it was reported they are on the verge
of death, we would, we would, but I would
report that.
But do you understand that that's not my language,
that's from other media outlets?
But other than that, as usual, the San Antonio
trial furious with me for things I never said.
Speaker 6: How does it feel being wrong is
so consistently?
And I would say something you have when you
go on to say that the is mismanaged COVID
worse than any other country, you don't even
mention Andrew Cuomo.
In fact, just saying Andrew Cuomo's name,
you've already hung the call up.
Speaker 1: And actually, I've criticized Cuomo
extensively.
Again, we I don't care about party.
I don't care about Democrats.
I don't care about Republicans.
DeSantis mismanaged COVID, Cuomo mismanaged
COVID in different ways.
We've talked about it all.
San Antonio troll either criticize me for
things I've said or call whoever is saying
this stuff because it certainly is not me.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join with Tactical.